gang the fall tour is about to kick off
and it's kicking off in a high gear baby
oh yeah five stand-up comedy plus we
play a little ayg with the crowd we're
coming to 20 new cities uh-huh grab the
squad and come out and see us it's a
good time and a great way to introduce
people to the show yeah tickets are
moving quick we're selling out we're
adding shows we're not adding shows in
every city so get your tickets don't
snooze Cause You're Gonna Lose do it
yeah welcome to another exciting edition
of are you garbage the show where you
find out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they're good to be
classy after just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host Dave Charlie coming
at y'all on a beautiful day we're out
back here at hoodies in the new edition
she's upstairs making some homemade ice
pops for the kids in the neighborhood
okay nine bucks a clip no big deal
trying to make a little cash my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
on a muse this week little swing in the
Miss on the big man he is the king of
the calzone he's the prince of the
personal pan the flatbread freak and
always the king of the boardwalk baby
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what
up gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure your rate of you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking baby then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
check it out it's a [__] party over
there yes sir it is and have a nice
quick shout out to our producer X Jordan
Air the magic man makes us all look good
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody hey pal what up boys
yeah dude we got a real [__] guy in
here man yeah this guy can blast 10-foot
airs and it looks like a sensitive lover
yeah I didn't expect that last minute
while true yeah there you go dang the
long hair ain't lying we couldn't be
more excited to have our incredibly and
I mean incredibly special guest here
with us today for the first time he is a
very funny very cool comedian podcaster
and radio personality he is also a
retired MMA fighter professional
skateboarder lead singer race car driver
that does it all former Guinness World
Record holder yeah they took it all
right
I want my day in court you [__]
he's got his own Festival he's a New
York Times bestseller gee you can hear
him every week on his two amazing
podcasts Hawk versus Ellis of course
popcorn is Wolf I'm sorry and of course
the Jason Ellis show and ladies and
gentlemen he's got a guillotine choco
that'll put you nightmare give it up for
Jason Ellis everybody let's go
man you guys are good you scared me when
you corrected me Jesus Christ that was
Pro as [__] buddy yeah thanks for coming
yeah thanks for having me man I'm stoked
[__] excited yeah you're an all-time
real dude I heard about you from the
youth oh yeah the young kids are out
there like chase you don't even know and
I'm like I guess I don't know
the youth is like 35 for us by the way
the youth is like 28. okay what's up
dudes we do about eight views on Tick
Tock 28 schooled me hi he was like what
do you mean you don't know and I'm like
man that's [__] sorry I'm very busy you
know like yeah I tried but I was told
that I'm an idiot for not knowing about
you guys thank you so much for coming
it's a good thing going here thank you
man I appreciate that give us the back
story give us the scoop give us the
childhood oh uh childhood was great
[Laughter]
the tattoos say otherwise
gold two thing Albany
I went to therapy and you're right I
built this to protect the fragile little
child carbon his dad's name in the table
yeah wow that he really did punch my
ticket for sure in so many ways
where'd you grew up down here in
Australia Melbourne Australia okay yeah
I grew I grew up when uh my dad was 20
and my mom was 16 when I was born so
yeah and they they were very young
didn't really I don't think they
was a bit of an accident
and he just kind of tried to roll with
it and then uh I think by the time I was
about four they broke up my dad ended up
my mom's best friend
married my dad and then there was this
drama because they were best friends and
she married my father and then I lived
with my father half the time and then in
the end it kind of my mum was in a rocky
world for she was an alcoholic she got
sober but there was a time there where
it was not that
friendly for kids and my dad was uh more
of a like he told me how to ride a dirt
bike and [__] like that so it was it was
easy I wanted to live there more and I
remember I had to make the decision and
my mom was very sad about it and I I
felt really bad about it dirt bikes
though what are you gonna do dude come
on as a kid it's either dirt bikes or
not I think it was just like do you want
to ride your dirt bike all day or do you
want to stay at your mom's it was pretty
easy yeah it sounds so cold
my stepmom had two more kids so I had
two uh younger half brothers and man we
are in it already she was already had
the kids no no they had him straight up
when they got together they because my
younger brothers one passed away but
once they were like five years apart
okay so my youngest was 10 years younger
than me sure gotcha so uh and did your
parents ever actually get married were
they married yes together yeah yeah they
were married okay so then they got
divorced your dad fell in love with her
friend yeah they got married yeah had
two more kids yeah and then dad started
making money okay
I lived in a like in a shitty
neighborhood and there was like drugs
and stuff like that I my mum's side had
some some uh heroin addicts like one of
her boyfriends offered me meth to stay
at a party and I was young enough I was
smart enough to know because I was tired
I wanted to leave and my mom was like I
gotta go and then he came in he was like
look I'll give you something to wake you
up but don't tell your mum [__] and just
when he said don't tell your mum I was
like right that's that sounds like it
could be bad this ain't great yeah so I
told her and it's a big fight and then
my father how old were you ballpark like
nine or something whoa God damn trying
to get you on the ice yeah yeah it's a
little early they are different down
under I got into it later but I mean it
had a sensible age like a gentleman yeah
yeah like a grown ass man I was hitting
that [__] like about 28 or something I
went straight for the meth how about a
Jolly Rancher or something a cup of
coffee
cartoons for you it was it was pretty
good but I didn't know because I blocked
it out but I didn't realize until I took
I took acid and and meth and I had and I
had an invisible uh friend that told me
in a swimming pool because I was in a
hotel pool and nobody could get me out I
was like growling at people like black
the [__] out and my girlfriend was like
I'll watch him he won't hurt me and then
I had an invisible friend tell me I was
molested by my father and that's when
all this other stuff unpacked yeah where
I was like wait what because that's not
me you know like I grew up I watched
Oprah and was like man those poor people
you know and I'm like wait I suck dick
God damn it so yeah then all that kind
of drama Ellis Came Out Swinging on this
Give me the give me the layout of the
neighborhoods
um like like are they Apartments houses
yeah apartments and you know junkies and
stuff like that because St Kilda is a
steaming pile of [__] is this
theoretically would be the suburbs of
Melbourne yep right yeah I just thought
the outskirts of the city though but
then my my father married my stepmom she
lived in the suburbs it was like a
little more family orientated so we got
to this place called Sandringham and
that's when my dad started making some
money so here we had a house my dad
ended up having like a bunch of cars but
that was kind of Rich for like when I
was about 12 wait
yeah about 12 to
17. he was he kept going bankrupt yeah
my dad I went back I didn't know but one
year I came because I was still trying
to be I was trying to be a pro
skateboarder so I go to America for six
months on a holiday Visa and come back
and he's like just so you know you can't
buy anything for a while and I was like
what do you mean and he's like oh I use
your name to run the business and and
then I made you go bankrupt oh and now
you set my mind's the business she went
bankrupt I think she he used my brother
at one point like he just kept running
he was pretty good at it that's the
Australian me by the way
in the end he was not that rich what was
he doing well how did he make his money
sell Electronics we used to own it
electronic parts like resistors and all
that kind of [__] and I worked there for
a little bit to get money to get a plane
ticket because nobody would give me a
job I'm too much of an [__] just like
a late you know skateboarder with no
skills I was just like I need money to
get to America to be Tony you know like
Tony pretty much the deal sure but uh it
was called Alice Tronics that's pretty
good man that's all right I don't hate
it yeah I'm talking what this is the set
80s yeah yeah that's a great 80s
Electronics
so we had a he like had an electronic
store yeah like a storefront and all
that stuff yeah yeah all right okay how
was his Courier for I I used to drive
all the uh integrated circuits
to uh sounds pretty clear I know it's
pretty good dude yeah it wasn't that bad
it was bad because he was the worst he
was like making a point that I'm the son
so it was always
treating me like yeah he's like he
didn't want anyone to look like I was
getting favored to them even though I
obviously was because I was nowhere near
qualified
that's why I ended up being a courier he
was like you can [__] drive a car you
[__] you know [__] off go deliver
this hooking up the power lines for the
township he lost it again and then he
sold the business to this other little
Asian guy who ran like a bunch of
electronic [__] in Australia so he sold
out to this guy my you know my dad was
his own boss and I remember really heard
him that this guy was now his boss and I
had to go over to this guy's house and
get boxes of electronic [__] put it in
the in the van and drive it deliver it
to places in one day there he shut the
[__] garage while I was walking out
backwards with the box so he [__]
shut the middle garage on the top of my
head
and I want to punch this dude in the
face I was like you did not [__] did
you have accidental my ass oh he had it
out for you but then when I started
doing gay [__] when I was older I went
to therapy for years over this but there
was a time there where I would just like
let people blow me like without shout
out to it talking to him or anything and
and a lot of them would be like little
Asian guys oh you think that's connected
let's get my power back yeah yeah okay
that's what my therapist told me so yeah
I stopped making little Asian people
blow me that sounded bad
adults that agreed to do it yeah and
they could leave through the garage
when did you start skateboarding uh I
think I first first started
when I was probably about 11 or
something like that but that was uh a
friend my mum's didn't she didn't have
any family and she had this other the
Johnsons who were like her Mum and Dad
okay were like my grandparents and they
had kids older and one of them was a
surfer who had the little plastic ones
in the in the shop and I found those so
my mum would hang out all day and I
would just ride this little plastic
thing those things were death traps and
then I met two twin brothers that were
like kind of Chuck one was chubby and
one was obese and we they were into
skating and then they told me about you
know Tony Hawk or and then I remember
you could get a very Flex skateboard and
it was the first wide wooden skateboard
I've ever seen they had wide trucks and
[__] and then once I found that that was
it right before that I made Escape
without a chipboard and and nailed
roller skate wheels on it and it didn't
roll after like five minutes so I just
started trying 360s in the driveway for
hours like it was just this thing that
sure I don't know what happened to me me
I never cared about anything but this
thing even the jankiest version of it
with no friends around no ramp no
hypnotized he [__] bit me man and
that was it I just couldn't stop
thinking about it saved my life because
I was had I had no plan no direction or
anything and no skill No need no wanting
of a skill just like [__] I hate this
place I don't know why well I do now but
at the time I was just like I [__]
hate everything and was there was there
a scene over there that you that you got
involved in the air in the air like I
found a ramp it was well first I found a
big bowl but they filled it in this big
Keyhole that was built in the 70s for
roller skaters I think so it still
existed and skateboarding was just
coming the 80s people hearing about Tony
Hawk like skateboarding was starting for
the first time yeah that's it that's so
there were a few people that had been
around before but not many most of us
were just like we we saw Back to the
Future that's that that did it too yeah
so then there was a half pipe that was
probably about half or half an hour away
from my house but a really little one
like on the scale of what you do now is
no one would even make it as the
transitions were about six foot and it
was like a 12 foot wide ramp real little
but there was a scene like 20 30 guys
and we just that was it I ended up like
not going to school and just going there
until until I got a report card and my
dad was like what the [__] and then I I
was a terrible liar so I was just like
yeah I was at the ramp so every day
you're skipping school you're doing that
and then I assume you get some notoriety
over there you don't just start flying
to the U.S no I was actually really bad
those two twin brothers were better than
me for the first three years and I just
it didn't look like I was ever going to
be good at it I just all I cared about
was going there and skating uh-huh and
then uh there's a few more ramps and
they got bigger and then the last one
was in parane closer to the city there
was like a full-scale ramp and I just
skated it every day and on one
particular day I learned how to uh do an
air without holding my board and my
friend was like you look like you could
do that as high as you want I was like
yeah right he's like just try it so I
tried a frontside Dolly about chest high
and I made it yeah and and I was like
what the [__] was that and he goes what
the [__] was that I'm like I'm gonna try
and do that again and I did I was like
what the [__] because in Australia no
one had done a front slide only that
High super bad and I had and I hadn't
done any of the other tricks that would
make it look like I could do a fight
really that high like I still hadn't
done a backflip air skateboarding stuff
but there's a chance I used to skate no
big deal well there's a tricky you could
do that you could go that high way
easier than doing a front satellite
especially in the 80s and then it was
like well what if I try to grab the tail
and in the Franco Dolly and then I did
that and no one had ever done a
frontside towel grabbing a straight
because it was a long time ago and then
sailfish and then I just I'll eat into
the leaner and I was like What if I go
back side I'll lead into an Indian and
then within an hour I became
20 times better than I was in the
morning and then by the next day the
skate shop guy was down there going with
this [__] guy's doing everyone
because everyone was talking like just
so you know Alice just became like it's
just the best keyboard in Australia
right in the top ten in Australia right
now that guy used to suck yesterday yeah
you should [__] see him today there
was a there was a guy that beat me up at
the skatepark like a week before that
like because he didn't like me or my
face or whatever and he got behind me
and hit me in the back of the head with
a skateboard and we had a fight and that
guy was still skating the vert with me
and was just like [__] you Alice and I'd
be like yeah [__] you and uh you know I
don't like confrontation I was scared I
was like man this makes skateboarding
really uncomfortable but then when I got
good sure like a week later everybody
likes you and it was my first experience
with like oh if you do fancy tricks
people like you yeah so of course
because the crazy there's no precursor
to this this is the 80s like yeah you
guys are you're making this up as you go
along a little bit I mean it's crazy by
then I half of the [__] I was doing was
the I was the first australian-born
person do it but it also grew I went to
America and learned all these other
things and came back and did them in
front of everybody and it was the same
thing when I went to America there was a
like 50 dudes that could do stuff that
sure I'd heard about but I'd never seen
it and when you see it you go oh that's
how you do that and then you kind of you
learn it and I feel like when I went
back home and did it then everybody
there was like oh that's how you do it
and then a few years later so who sends
you over you said you went over five six
at a time you just paid for yourself
[__] yeah there was no sponsor nothing
like that you were like I want to do
this okay I had I set my parents down
there you're 16 years old right yeah
yeah that's nuts I stand up and sat him
down I was like I'm gonna I need money
to get to America so I need a job but
then when I get there I'll be a pro
skateboarder and then you won't need to
give me any money anymore and my dad was
like that's not a job and I was like it
is a job and I didn't have any proof I
couldn't show the magazine we didn't
have the magazine yet we just had gossip
then Thrasher came a bit later and then
the Bones Brigade video came America
already had it but we didn't yeah like
when I got Escape magazine and a video
it was in a water ski shop in the back
where they saw water speed shops yeah
well I don't know I don't know anymore
because it does exist here that's hyper
focused I'm not talking wakeboard I'm
talking [__] you got single skate you
got your jump skate and like it was damn
yeah back to the parachute store yeah it
was like Max's water ski world or some
[__] like that Jesus yeah Max was all
right that's what I heard it's never had
a shirt on yeah I think Max Toby Tony
there's a guy in America can do finger
flips and I'm like nah that's impart
that doesn't even make any sense and
then the magazine came in I'm like wow
also Oh no just like a life level of
like obviously in the 80s the lack of uh
information moving quickly yeah you just
hear of this Legend of this guy Tony
Hawk doing kind of made it better and
then but like now you're his [__] boy
how crazy is that did you hear about
this fictitional character yeah and then
that'd be like me being like oh yeah me
and Seinfeld are now best friends it
doesn't go away that's [__] awesome
because we do shows down at the ramp and
often it's just us two doing the podcast
and then afterwards we skate yeah and I
might I'm skating
it's just me and Tony that's [__]
crazy it's Tony and I whatever but it's
I I will just slap myself in the face
from time to time or especially when now
that we're older and we're like more
fragile sure and it's like if we hit our
head now is that that's the last time
right like like we got family now that
go hey how many times you've been
knocked out this year you know can you
go yeah yeah good point maybe I should
slow down like that that is a thing now
damn so it's like more of a you know I'm
gonna try something that's like
another OG on the podcast uh-huh and
what a switch since Jump Street yeah
baby and they just keep getting better
and better I know new things now they
got the weed whacker they got the
lawnmower 4.0 the weed whacker they're
already on two they got they became the
best in abyss and they ain't wrestling
on The Laurels baby they're innovating
over there and here's the good news you
don't got to get them separately you can
get it on the performance package 4.0 we
ain't talking 1.0 2.0 3.0 we're talking
Four Points everything you need for
grooming uh-huh [__] Soup To Nuts
down there they got the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer to weed whacker 2.0 for ear nose
hair by the way body day that creeps up
on you when you reach a certain age I'm
there they got the crop preserver the
anti-chafing ball deodorant crop the
toner because my lady likes a nice Tone
Ball I don't know about yours tight yeah
I got a real tight Saga to Tone It Up
Baby like a basketball uh the only thing
I use I use the trimmer I've said a
bunch I've used it on my balls I use it
on my face I use it all over the chest
it's Beach season I gotta trim up keeps
the sweat down keeps the stink away
gotta try my hamburger meat I got up
here yeah uh keep the property value up
sure you gotta cut the grass can't let
the neighbors get upset uh here we go
baby here's the turkey you get 20 off
and free shipping with the code garbage
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscapes.com use the code
garbage manscape the perfect way to get
your panties sizzling hot this summer
baby do it Kippy do you like that box of
awesome uh you mean bespoke post the
best box in the whole gosh darn Lane
best holiday all year long that's when
that puppy shows up at the door ding
dong box days here let's go gang they
got tons of fun products you got outdoor
stuff you got grooming stuff anything
you could possibly want they got a cram
doing a nice little box small businesses
fantastic company yeah gang uh I've said
it a bunch they send me something every
month it's fantastic fantastic I open it
up it's always something cool like I I
wrote a knife heavy bike next to the bed
I used to open up my Amazon packages
like a lady uh it's uh easy to get
started just take the quiz at box of
awesome.com and get matched with your
perfect box each box is valued around
seventy dollars but you only pay a
fraction of that 90 of everything in
your box is going is coming from a small
up and coming brand like the big man
said so you're getting in an incredible
deal every single month now here's the
juice okay 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
enter the code garbage and check out
that's box of awesome.com code garbage
for 20 off your first box one more time
get a pen box awesome.com code garbage
do it gang did you take your parents out
of the ramp to show them how how good
you were at it no no did that connect
one time they came one time one time my
Dad paid for me to go in a contest where
American Pros were there and because I
was late I ended up being in a heat with
them and there's a video I showed Tony
which is [__] hilarious where he's
standing on the deck and I'm I'm
standing here and I go
[Laughter]
I can see that my [__] father's
holding a cat I'm like
look at that and then and then because
Tony looks my way I look I don't want to
get eye contact so I look away from him
but he's seen the video of me being 16
and trembling in the presence and now
and he's a kid too at the time for the
most part he was a bit yeah no yeah but
not two or 16 year old sure he was like
20 you know in his 20s right and he was
already Tony Hawk like he hadn't he'd
been around he was a freak we were all
trembling in his presence yeah and
rightly so and when you would come over
here where would you stay couches and
[__] you'd stay in the first couple days
I slept in a kid's playground I brought
a sleeping bag because we came to
[__] go like I did not I didn't
expect anything if you come solo by
yourself game with another guy really
yeah and we slept in a kitchen just on
your own yeah well the other guy nude
the other guy knew people I found out
many years later we stayed at Lance
Mountain's house and we lived there for
like a couple months until he was like
you gotta go and we didn't know I didn't
know this until my 50th birthday Lance
Mountain came to my 50th birthday and
told me the story of when he first met
me and was like yeah yeah your friend
just [__] knocked on the door dude
and was like Hey we're here he didn't
talk to me about staying and then you
guys just stayed and Lance was a guy
that was trying to he knew that we loved
skateboarding sure it was like I want to
help you guys progress but at the same
time I don't really know you guys like
that well and you're definitely over
saying sure because we didn't have
anywhere else to go and where else would
I want to go Lance Mountain's house with
Lance mountains ramp in the backyard and
that was I became pro at in those three
months I learned three tricks a day I
made sure I did
it's [__] wild dude Lance Mountain's
a legendary skateboarder it's just like
comedy though like you go like I go to
the to the The Comedy Store and
like Mark Maron walks by and then
doesn't sit and I'm like [__] yeah you
know like Bobby Lee and all these people
are right there right in front of me and
it's it's just like MMA I'm a child
again yeah you know even if I'm older
than you I just go oh [__] I mean it's
it's it's Tim Dillon you know like and
he's like what the what [__] what do
you want that's him do it get out of my
way yeah
Local's only [__]
the first time I met him out of here I
picked up a security guard I just did
like my second set at The Comedy Store
ever because of Ryan sickler he got me
on there shout out to shout out to
secular and I was in The Green Room and
Tim Dylan comes in and I'm and I said to
myself holy [__] Tim Dylan and he goes
hey man that was a good set I was like
thank you Tim Dylan and then he goes you
want to do a sit with me and I'm like
yeah he's like yo come back tomorrow and
and uh just said a Masha I'm like okay
and then I get there and uh it's just
him in the green room and he goes
where you ever lived in the east coast
and I was like no why and he goes well
you're here
and I'm like what do you mean he's like
everybody else isn't here you're here oh
on time yeah L.A Comics don't show up
and I was like wait to the to a Tim
Dillon gig at The Comedy Store and he's
like yeah and then he went up first and
left he called a few other people so
then I witnessed this guy get a whole
new lineup of the same caliber like
Andrew Schultz shows up instead I'm like
you can just call Andrew's show how you
guys are [__] crazy yeah it was and
then when I came back to be like Tim
Dale it already left
son of a [__] I guess I didn't do that
good
what are you doing uh food wise spending
money wise when you come over here that
young sack of potatoes like it's the
1400s baby hey man I wasn't a smart kid
all right I was just like dude the fact
that you did that is insane I mean that
is that's [__] that's crazy it lasted
a long time halfway around the world and
skateboarders are fan like when you
skate like I skip when I showed up I
skated like a like it's everything to me
and all the other guys that were Pros
could tell this kid is gonna be a is one
of us okay so there was like you don't
have any food dude like do you want to
stay at my like Ben comedy's the very
comedy is very similar it's like well if
you're a comedian you're in the you're
in the group Ben Schroeder let me live
in his house for like six months like
half a until my Visa until my holiday
Visa was up but in these mum came in one
time and sang it Miss Sung to me about
how it was time for me to leave me and
Ben were just sitting in on the couch
super high and she came in it's been
nice knowing you but you gotta go Jason
I'm just like wait but you were staying
at his mom's place at his family's house
oh my God yeah he didn't have a house
get your [__] and hit the road yeah yeah
yeah who got played off like the Grammys
yeah
starts playing closing time
it took a couple of verses
I was like wait that's me that's me all
right right I'll go
holy [__] so you did that for a couple
years back and forth four years four
years in the fourth year is when I got
sponsored and got a deal when you get
sponsored got it tonight you're
celebrating sponsor me for 700 600 a
month and then you're living high on the
hog I gotta raise the 700 the next year
so I was feeling it feeling pretty good
and then I went to Vancouver for the
Slam City Jam I've been Pro for a bit
now and on the way back into from Canada
to America they go
were you at that skateboard contest and
I was like yeah and like you are you a
skateboarder I was like yeah but I was
just watching I'm just here to watch out
I mean like why you go to America so
much I'm like I just love America like
Disneyland like just lying out my ass
and he's like do you have any money to
prove that you have money when you go
back into America I was like of course I
do he's like where is it I'm like it's
in my bank account and he's like I'm
gonna Deport you if you don't show me
money and I was like I'll just get a
bank statement and come back and he goes
okay and I don't have any money so I
went back out of customs and left the
airport got a taxi back to the city and
called
these dudes the Red Dragons that like
run Vancouver skateboarding and I called
Moses in a at a payphone and he's like
where are you and I'm I'm on the corner
of something then something and he came
down had some joints for me it was like
you could stay at my house then I lived
at his house with him and Colin McKay
who's also another legendary skateboard
and they were like you need to get on
the Bones Brigade those guys they got
lawyers they'll get you an athlete Visa
so wait are these Red Dragons crime
related no okay they sound real gnarly
that's what I'm saying you can't just
say the Red Dragons came and picked me
up on the corner we all have giant red
dragon you're part of the Red Dragons
yeah yeah I'm the first
non-canadian-born red dragon man we have
a game we have a gang sign and [__]
was for security when we go skate like
security be like you guys need to get
the [__] out of here and we'd be like no
are you talking to yeah because we were
a little we had a couple of Heavies in
the in the group sure that could like
push back and then because we pushed
back the littler guys had an attitude
where sure you're like you got to get
the [__] out of him like you need to get
the [__] out of here and then you know
we would keep skating police would chase
us we would run no real skate parks not
well accepted all that kind of weird
Canada has skateparks but the streets
were forbidden like here in this
downtown and you're skating a ledge
people cops there's like cops on bmx's
on mountain bikes and they would Chase
everybody I'm not even a street skater I
would just go there to start [__] this
is Wild West that's a real rabble route
a little bit one time pushed the
security guy through a play Class Window
Jesus it's just a Life and Times of a
red dragon member
the only member of the Yakuza who can
take
[Applause]
go hit this hand roll then we're gonna
steal we're gonna rob that bank okay
guys I'm running around Canada with a
newsie
so I can pop it at the top of a limo hey
hey hey keep it down all right yeah it's
between us
holy [__] all right so when do you start
making a like
a little bit of money where you where
you're you're okay the Buns Brigade the
Bones Brigade yeah they started paying
me like two or three grand a month nice
then I got a shoe sponsor what year are
we talking if you don't mind me asking
it
90s not late 90s two three grand in the
90s let's [__] go you're right when
you go back to Australia because the
exchange rate it was double so in
Australia I was making the [__]
killing six or seven maybe eight grand a
month all up and and I didn't have a
house or didn't pay taxes because I
didn't know about that so I was yeah
living ahead so what are the chains and
[__] I I thought I was stupid purchases
oh yeah only yes yeah I didn't buy
anything that I have now yeah welcome to
the show great way to put it I didn't
buy anything I have now that's great
I've never thought of it that way it's
all gone oh no I've got a red dragon
chain still okay you got it I bought a
diamond necklace like [__] five grand
like I don't have any money but I got a
five thousand dollar necklace yeah
[__] idiot damn so when you go back
after this you got money in your pocket
professional skateboarder what are the
folks saying then oh um
I I don't know are they not get it uh
the only time I remember my dad being
proud of me is my one of his work
colleagues said that did you know Jason
that was pink
he's friends with pink because I'm
president you know pink what the [__] so
that was the first time I ever heard
it's like the Forest Gump of the X game
it said I said he's been everywhere he's
a red dragon he's friends with pink
beating up a security guard at a bus
stop Pete probably did too so leave me
alone
holy [__] but he went to one demo he
came to one demo with his friends with
which is where he came to the demo with
uh a guy friend that he'd been friends
with for years and his wife
I ended up sleeping with her for a
couple years and her two sisters so it
was like this weird thing where she came
and I knew why she came but yeah you did
there was a demo where it was like real
good guys and I was it was good and that
was the the one time where
uh
I was like you guys cannot deny that
look what I'm doing here yeah I'm doing
10 foot is in this demo you know I mean
with this other guy who's the best dude
in the world and I don't look any worse
than him sure this is a good look but
the first time he actually I got a check
delivered to the house and he saw it
I'll never forget it he goes three grand
what's this for I said skateboarding he
goes how often do they give me these I
was like every month he's like every
month you should take this [__] serious
what the [__] man I was like what do you
think I've been doing he's like I
thought you've been selling weed the
whole time
[__] holding out on me so you've been
selling weed though you better take this
[__] serious that's an all-time parent
from not understanding what to yelling
at you before it my mom hit me the other
day she's like are you writing new
material I'm like shut the [__] up lady
[__] job's hard enough wow because
we're doing a Big Show in Philly
Philly serious [__] need this [__]
from you I'm a red dragon
all right I want to go back to Australia
a little bit because you're the first
Australian we've had on okay we have a
lot of
Clint we have a lot of Australian fans
and the big thing is the Bogan yeah
right so it's like you're a Bogan oh
yeah you know but Bogan is there when my
dad died they're trash it's their my dad
died then my brother died like around
the same year and we had a another wake
at my brother's house and this one was
uh we did burnouts in the garage put
dirt bikes in the garage with the with
the with the garage door down
I had uh a joint in my mouth bike in
[__] six gear pin just bad [__]
smoke everywhere some other black smoke
everywhere we're just doing burnouts in
the garage giving ourselves uh carbon
monoxide poisoning and then uh it's like
what's the point of having the garage
door down because holds the smoke more
you can't see where you're going
it's just real Bogan [__] I presume duh
you [__] what the [__] seriously got a
[__] question was that I apologize just
told you we're trying to get carbon
monoxide poisoning you [__] asking
why we're morning here I [__] told
you why Brad awake you're trying to
[__] die in this dead guy's respect
you know
but I get out of the garage I get out of
the garage I'm coughing feel pretty sick
that mission accomplished you don't say
here we go well I sit out against the
side of the house and and uh my brother
brings this guy over
the Bogan looking guy in Australia is
like uh it's it's racist term now but
it's like if you're Italian and Greek
you're a [__] okay and when you were
younger you'd be like that's pretty good
when you were younger it'd be like Jimmy
the [__]
Jimmy we might gotta bring that one back
Jimmy called himself a wall yeah right
so it wasn't but you could say it yeah
yeah now I don't think it's a good idea
I think things have changed it's been a
long time since Kane and Greek [__] them
what are you talking about yeah I know
it's a touchy subject right now I did
not say that I did not say that
sounds like a good guy any [__] way
[__] done like this this guy comes
over and he's from this ethnicity right
but he's called the burnout King and and
he's introduced to me as the burnout
King and he's very serious and he goes
Jace mate you mean I knew your dad you
know what I mean he's a top bloke you
know your [__] brother's a sick [__]
mate he may have got nothing but respect
for your [__] family and I want to
[__] do something in appreciation for
a mate could I do that and I was like
yes burnout you could do that he's like
come outside mate I've got something for
you and I go okay and we go out there
and he's got his car out in the street
already that he's put another tire on I
can already tell he's put another tire
on one side because it's not a limited
slip diff it's a car that when you bag
it up only one wheel's gonna crank and
he knows it okay so he [__] uh
immediately he's like just staying there
you know what I mean he gets in the car
got the door open starts the car up
immediately just [__] bags it up
starts shifting this thing's smoking up
and he opens the door he looks back so
he watches the tire while he's doing it
and I'm like this guy's a [__] Pro
like this is a top burnout it starts
going I mean smoking that's a crazy
sentence dude
if you're a Bogan you know like when
someone doesn't like that you're like
this guy's done thousands of things not
not like one time every now and then
when he's drunk this [__] happens
regular so he starts doing this burnout
[__] smoke everywhere everyone's
getting pumped then the brake pad thing
is go is glowing red you mean because
it's been gone for so long and we're
we're raging and we're getting closer
because of the light and then [__]
boom [__] tire pops this guy stays on
the hammer doesn't back off at all and
we run we've rushed the car because it
blew up you know I mean we're bogans
we're like [__] yeah we run at it and as
I run at it sounds like a soccer team
the bogans boiling hot Tire Cubs
flicking off everywhere and starts
burning everybody we're all getting
burnt and we're all laughing because you
know
it's that sure we want it sure
we are bogans
and then this guy's still going and then
the the tire catches on fire and then
the back of his car's on fire and he's
just out the door going
this is like mad this guy is [__]
giving it like he's wrecking his car so
then it's you know Standing Ovation
everyone's freaking out he [__]
finally stops and we put his car out
pouring water on it and [__] and he's
like you know there you go mate you know
that's what you guys like thank you
Jesus Christ like seriously and that guy
became my friend he's still my friend I
follow him on Instagram he's got like uh
his name's he's got I think it's at
dizzle's but he makes he's got he sells
barbecue meat he makes sells his own
barbecues bogans are all right yeah he's
cooked on a hot tube
he wanted me to post these barbecues
he's selling barbecues mate you reckon
you can give me a [__] repost
anything you want burnout King
for what you did for my family when we
were grieving anything you want yeah
because he [__] he fixed this you
know yeah we were all [__] laughing
for a minute he [__] fixed it that's
a [__] funeral what was the mullet
situation at that funeral
[Laughter]
required
there's a couple if you were you had to
have one to be a pallbearer yeah
holy [__] dude okay all right all right
that's [__] wild dude Kip this is
Factor baby shout out to the Boys At
Factor yeah they're all right over there
they know what they're doing in the
kitchen I'll tell you that they know
everybody gets busy I know and what's
the first thing that you start slipping
on the meals good nutritious meals you
hit the drive through you get to take
out a pizza man myself Factor has got
you covered the number one meal kit sent
right to your door heat it up you throw
in a microwave two minutes or what Kippy
does he throws it on a skillet puts it
on a plate like a gentleman cause I'm a
fancy pants boy they're good stuff man
you have a nice nutritious meal in two
minutes you're ready to go you don't got
to worry about nothing stay on top of it
yeah factors fresh never frozen meals uh
meal times are so quick easy and you get
to that delicious delicious meal with
over 34 weekly restaurant quality
options there's always something new to
try I log in it sends you an email it's
like hey your thing's going out tomorrow
jump in beep you pick and choose what
you want I'm a shredded chicken taco
bowl man myself I say give me 10 of them
uh you head to Fat my wife hates him I
had the factor doc factor75.com garbage
50 and use the code garbage 50 to get 50
off Jesus really there we go that's code
garbage 50 at factor75.com garbage 50 to
get 50 off that's got to be a typo
they're giving it away baby check it out
for yourself over there factor75.com
slash garbage 50 to it try it out gang
my dad's funeral we just did a nice
little luncheon
[__] [__]
I had to put their Ash we have a house
in the mountains it's where they both
died too and I had to put their ashes on
the or we have a we built like a
motocross track in the front of the
house like just dug it all up because my
brother raced he was like top two in
Australia like proper racer okay so we
built it he helped and my dad helped
build like a Supercross track out the
front so when he died we had to put the
ash we put the ashes all over the track
and then I know from the Australia the
law with the guns where they said you
know if you give your illegal guns back
you get money for them you don't get in
trouble well my dad gave most of his
guns back sure but I knew that there was
two guns that he kept and I knew where
they were and my stepmom didn't so after
he died I grabbed this one it's only a
22 but it's got a 16 uh
16 shot magazine okay so it's like and
it's semi-automatic and semi-automatic
is illegal even if it's a 22 so I get on
the balcony of my father's bedroom and
everyone's downstairs
and my stepmom is down there and she
goes Jason and I'm like whoa what she's
like what the [__] what get down here
and I'll say oh [__] because I kind of
thought maybe I was in charge now
but no I'm not yeah no don't pull your
card real [__] yeah but I I was like
oh wow that so I thought I was gonna fly
yeah you're like I'm the man of the
house she's like no you're not I'll put
that get down here and clean your room
yeah actually no I gave it back to the
police there you go turned it in yep I
mean this guy was worried about saying
Wong and then he's talking about a
[__] semi-automatic weapons in
[__] Australia you're crazy I was
about to say so you have a mountain
house that sounds pretty nice but they
put a dirt bike track in the front of it
they're dirt bike people but it's front
that's a backyard obstacle well there's
not a lot of neighbors okay so it's kind
of it's in the bush
ah the bush yeah it's like really in
there okay serious business over there
yeah the bush don't play and you know
you can walk around naked and shoot guns
there just not with me stepmom's around
did you always have that like all
growing up uh no it's just a camp in the
bush when we were younger and then when
my dad had some money he built like a
log cabin I ended up I ended up helping
build it because I didn't have a job and
he gave me the job so another friend of
his that was a carpenter he and I moved
up there and lived there and helped
build like I built Curacao the [__]
like making like concrete and building
[__] steps and [__] I didn't know
what I was doing I just did what I was
told
yeah but I was Pro in Australia if that
means anything I thought I was hot [__]
still but yeah building that building
that house but we it was one of those
things where we we built it like we got
all the rocks from the river we didn't
spend it's not a log cabin like when you
go to the snow here like Mammoth and
stuff and you see log cabins they're all
straight you know they're built by
professionals like it looks like
Sylvester Stallone's house and [__] rich
people [__] what a weird pool
I always think a log cabins I think a
slide are you referring it was log cabin
in uh Rocky IV yeah
there's a [__]
that was nice when you were building
that was there like snakes and spiders
and [__] running around yeah yeah yeah
nuts not you guys are [__] idiots
Australia look at that it's not like
[__] snakes shocks are flying at me
everywhere you gotta catch me yeah I
think it is because there's snakes and
they don't [__] come for you you
gotta [__] stand on it which means
you gotta like walk around blind they
don't they don't you know I mean like I
never go in the bush like ah [__]
look wow look at that they're all over
the place run they're [__] everywhere
like it's not it's got a knife on them
that never happened but pulling the
house down because it was an old shed
and I had to pull all the uh all the
roofing and all the [__] off and take
the insulation out and every sheet of
insulation I took out there was hundreds
of huntsmans hunts into the big hairy
spiders so it is like that yeah what are
you talking about but they're not
poisonous
[Applause]
they're not tarantulas they're [__]
Huntsman and they don't buy it so it's
more like you just flush them out of the
way yeah what about in the house growing
up uh towards the city was there any
spiders or anything like that like just
huntsman's that's it yeah how big's a
huntsman pretty big yeah okay that's it
you're saying pretty big I was scared of
spiders I woke up with one on my chest
an Australian tourism I had to stay down
with it until my mum woke up and flicked
it off
so that one [__] with me a little bit
I was scared of scared of spiders for a
while but I cured myself when I moved to
America because I lived with dudes that
knew that I was scared of him and they
kept putting them on me or dead ones or
pretending doing the thing with the
feather on your ear and [__] in the end
where they did it so much I was like
[__] put on my [__] mouth I don't
[__] care anymore and they cured me
yeah what's that immersion therapy or
whatever yeah and my show we did stunts
where we had Pat a predator where I had
a pet guy come in that had snakes
lizards and spiders it's half a predator
and they were all aggressive ones so the
whole point was if you put your hand in
the Box it's not gonna maybe bite yeah
it's gonna [__] bite ya so I've had a
trench a big fat hairy tarantula like I
go to put my hand in the box and he goes
and I'm like are you [__] joking me
like it's not it sees me and it's like
do it yeah I [__] dare you to do it
and put it in there and it comes over
[__] ah yeah [__] sauce biting you
but it doesn't hurt it just looks scary
like the actual because I got bit by
like a eight foot anaconda tried
desperately trying to get the show on
his way to school what well this is what
at one time this guy from South Africa
that like slept with snakes in Vegas in
a glass house like in a mall for like a
week like he's out of his mind on him
and he came in with one and he pulled it
out of the bag put it on the table and I
was like [__] and everybody after the
show was like dude you're so scared of
snakes you're Australian how's that
possible am I it's not like what I said
they don't I haven't been attacked by a
snake my whole life so then I called the
guy and said do you have a really big
snake that will bite me because I
thought for the for the radio if you're
scared of snakes and you go there's an
eight foot anaconda and it's gonna bite
this guy that's scared of snakes will
you change the channel That was my
theory
so I was right but also right when the
six had three people holding this thing
because it was so big nuts and he goes
put your arms and as soon as I put my
arm out it just went whap under my wrist
and then started to try and grab my arm
and pull the skin off and those dudes
wrestled it off and then we had another
game we had him come back in he was my
friend for where I did photo shoots with
him I did an ESPN the magazine photo
shoot where I had to go underwater with
the snake and hold it
while it was looking at me and scream at
it man you are the complete opposite of
Foley this is nuts I just really wanted
the show to work I don't I I don't enjoy
I feel like guess what Jace The Snake's
back for this show I'd be like [__] I
don't know I don't like him I mean I
want to say that if he's listening I'm
scared of him sure yeah but for the show
for this for the sake of the
entertainment yeah I've always been
committed to it
Jesus you're [__] rule dude I think
the skateboarding in the Moto and stuff
made it easier you know like if you get
hurt a lot you know like I've broken
like over 50 Bones have been knocked out
over 20 times when you when you go to
hospital and get surgeries and you and
you do all the things that I've done
sneak by doesn't seem that bad yeah I
remember like am I going to the
emergency room after this and if the
answer is no then it's not really that
bad I remember being a kid watching you
on TV you know it was younger watching
you would be like this guy's [__]
nuts I'm not even then I meet you and
I'm like you're [__] actually crazy
wait that doesn't make sense to you
I'm trying to make the show work what
else am I going to do gay porn is not a
high-paying job like I don't have a lot
of abilities the radio show if I make it
like I saw Howard Stern I'm telling
people tell me he gets 100 million I'm
like I just want one million give me one
you give me one million like it's an
easy deal sure sure
holy [__] man you're my kind of nuts
huh
man screw the ringer I think I got
spiders
have to take photo to a psychiatrist
after this man you guys are so good at
talking today that's crazy that is heavy
duty well uh back a little bit
he's going back
Jesus Christ
he's got money in air conditioning now
let's talk about that
what kind of sushi do you like
Jesus Christ well we know new money
American [__] I want to know I want to
know poor Australian [__] because
apparently it sounds like the [__]
1500s yeah I'll give you a rich guy that
Huntsman coming after I want to be a
rich guys sorry I went to dinner last
night with Tony Hawk shout out to the
Birdman some restaurant that gave us
like six a six course menu that turned
into a nine course because the chef
wanted to show Tony Hawk a little extra
of what they do and then we get brought
into the kitchen just us and get meet
the chef and get treated to a dessert at
the chef table it's like uh what's that
movie where everybody kills each other
on the island menu the menu yes oh yeah
they're just super ain't the the the
chefs were just like all organized and
everything was crazy put together it was
like that chef's table in the kitchen
that's about classes again sure but okay
so at the same time you're uh what are
you wearing to an event to a dinner like
that because you're you're obviously a
very cool guy you were like you are that
guy you could just wear like a black
T-shirt and jeans
when you dress up what's that like I
wear suits yeah yeah you got a lot of
suits you a suit guy uh I got like three
it's all right I got like a Gucci suit
and [__] I get down all right there we
go oh no I'm uh now we're talking it's
like ghetto fabulous kind of sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was like I mean I
saw oh wait Gucci's the most expensive
thing yeah I'll get one of those oh
Gucci shoes with magic jacket done deal
what Gucci sunglasses [__] boom I'm a
poser for sure I was out front of the
Hollywood uh improv the other day and
the security guy goes
uh are you are you somebody important
and they go I mean I I think I am here
and he goes yeah you look you dress like
you think you're important
pretty much sums me up that's what I was
going for you
see you in there no it was a real ego
booster for sure what color are those
suits
uh
uh one's black
one's uh the
the Gucci one is is black and dark blue
and the jacket has like the Bumblebees
on it like printed in you can barely see
it but it's pretty and then I have the
Bumblebee shoes and belt to match like I
don't [__] play okay you know how to
tie a tie yeah okay yeah you're on a top
I went to private school and then I got
expelled for breaking a fat kid's arm
but I didn't why are you looking at me
sorry about that they're both here
where do you want me to look
I feel better
my arm
[__] [__] [__] red dress she
went to private school yeah my grandma
was because she owned the electronics
store and she was rich and she tried it
because I was bad at school and she was
like we'll fix him and we'll put him in
private school sure last ditch effort
she paid for it and then I this kid
stole my marbles I won and he was like
this is great he's like nah I win and
I'm like nah that's not how that goes
and then we got into a push and shove
thing and I I [__] hit him and he
fell and his arm got stuck in the bench
as he fell I didn't [__] Focus his
arm sure I was like that's on him yeah I
was like 12 or something so he said I'm
broke and I was like ah [__] that looks
bad and then uh principal because they
used to beat you I used to get hit with
the belt in the cane and [__] and then
yeah he [__] bench over and [__]
crack here leave marks and [__] and then
he did it to me and before my dad got
there and my dad got there my dad's a
Bogan yeah my dad don't say but that's
not from money you know my dad head
butts people quick too like you [__]
great Australians go for it I never saw
him lose a fight one time one time he
got close fought a guy in an Alleyway
after work and I was there what wait
what what my dad was parked out the
front and my friend was there to meet me
we're gonna go skate and I was I was
like give us a ride he's like [__] off
I've got to go somewhere we're probably
gonna go bone somebody and this guy
comes flying by in the alleyway real
close to Dad's car and he goes what the
[__] and then a guy hits the brake stops
and just points at the ground and my dad
goes yo [__] go [__] and then he gets
out of the car and the guy's real big
tall guy and I'm like ah [__] but he
looks
and I'm in front of my dad going dad
stop it's not worth it because I don't
like that stuff and I mean I'm like just
don't you know me don't he's like get
out of the [__] way and then right
before I'm in the middle of a punch on I
move out of the way my dad starts
smashing him up against the wall and
then a dude hits the wall and he can
[__] fire he front kicked me my dad
in the chest and my dad bounced from the
other side hit his back on the on the
other Alleyway wall and I just blacked
out and I and I remember the guy was
really tall so I jumped up high while he
was facing my dad and got him into like
the schoolyard headlock sure and then I
put him in his car door like punching
him you did yeah so now you and your dad
are beating this guy yeah my dad was
just watching at this point I I had him
in there your tag team and a dude I
started slamming his head
I started slamming his head in his door
not cool like I was crying you mean like
[__] touch my [__] dad you know
[__] like that and then I was like
you're [__] done and he's like yeah
I'm done I'm wrong [__] off and pushed
him in his car and then I walk off and
my dad starts walking next to me and he
goes you took your [__] time to jump
in
and I looked at him let her get a couple
licks in huh I looked at him and out of
shock I mean like what are you [__]
talking about he's like just just joking
yeah I was like can I get a ride down
he's like nah he's still left the [__]
man I was like I just [__] helped you
man
you got into a fight with your dad in
the alleyway yeah I've been I mean I saw
a lot of fights oh I didn't that's why
that's why I was always scared of
Confrontation because I see my dad
pretty [__] good at it they know
their teeth come out of their mouth with
one punch and I was like what happens if
I fight a guy like him I don't want to
go I don't want my teeth punched out of
my face so I was always scared that's
why I got into MMA after being a pro
skateboarder because I knew how scared I
was of it you know and it irked me it's
kind of like comedy like I was so scared
of it that I was like why do it yeah I'm
so fascinated as to why I have this fear
so I trained to get to feel like I can
take care of myself
damn the first time I had obviously I I
obviously knew who you were he a couple
years ago with skank Fest I thought you
were gonna follow up with some lacrosse
Camp story or something like what no no
no that was a good move not to no he uh
this one time I told a kid to go [__]
himself
I made up a rollerblader on the
boardwalk uh it was when you were it was
you were at it was at skank Fest and you
walked in in like we were at the
breakfast bar at the in Houston yeah and
I didn't I mean I know who you were I I
hadn't met you yet and me and him were
having breakfast and you walk in [__]
you know like shorts and like a tank top
or whatever and he doesn't he doesn't
know who you are he goes who the [__] is
that guy he goes Kippy look at this
[__] dude
I go that's the guy fighting Lewis and
he's like oh what the [__]
yeah this guy's nuts I'm like yeah he's
[__] yeah he's a red dude man
I am over the top Jesus Christ I know
like a superhero yeah super poser he's
talking about here's real as it gets
dude
um Jesus yeah I mean
I
I have enough information to render a
decision
yeah but I gotta know a couple of things
now we're not [__] going anywhere I'm
just saying I'll tell you that the rest
is formalities are done could you make
it
we're about to launch a spin-off are you
opposium have you hosted in Australia
man you would get a lot of guests
yes I have your family you got to get
the burnout King on first
I forgot about the burger probably give
you a discount on the barbecue but hold
on so your grandmother had money this is
your dad's mom yeah yeah so was she a
Bogan too nah nah she was this isn't
something you're born in good person
okay nah I think it came from I don't
think my grandfather paid much attention
I think he did some bad stuff because
yeah I don't want to get into that no
that's okay that's okay 100 but but she
had the electronic store it went to your
dad yeah my grandfather's lost lost his
mind a little bit after she died gotcha
but there was he did run it and then he
married a girl that was the same age as
my dad and she tried to take the
business so there was a lot of my dad
didn't like his dad gotcha okay but you
went to private school for a minute yeah
when I went back to Bogan school after I
got expelled and that's something that's
just a public school right I went to man
I went out I decided to go to school
where my mum lives after that and that
was where it was just
I got beat up in the cricket nets for a
whole lunch break I don't even know what
that sentence means getting beat up in
the baseball cage for a whole lunch
break
it's theoretically a classy I thought
they were catching crickets Cricket's a
classy spot not in Australia like maybe
if you're playing for Australia yeah but
even those guys are like it's different
now you're not allowed to be what you
were the the legends of cricket in the
80s were fat drunk cigarette smoking
dudes that like punched on at the pub
after they won or lost didn't matter
like they would be on the news for
assaulting fans at a pub the night after
and then or I quit they got uh Nicorette
sponsor and then you catch the guy
smoking a cigarette at the pub
those are the cricket guys I grew up in
years
I think now it's a little different you
know all right all right okay yeah it
was a different scene and if you're just
an amateur Cricket player and then
you're just a Bogan okay now the term
bug like would you say well somebody say
like that's some Bogan [__] if someone
goes you're a Bogan with the does that
cause you to fight or is it not like uh
no it's more in Australia it it's it's
dying because the world's changing and
you know there's red light cameras in
Australia there's cameras now on
freeways if you break the speed limit
the photo goes off and you get busted so
bogans can't live you know because if
you're a Bogan you're getting our Bogan
if you're a Bogan you do burnouts
everywhere you go you speed yeah you
[__] love the burnouts [__] yeah you
do it's crazy you can't call yourself a
Bogan if you don't [__] peel out
every day what really what would be good
yeah I peel out every [__] day
I can't even afford my car anymore and
I'm not giving it up because I know what
are you whipping around then what's a
Bogan like you well
I'm around the smoking so I go to M3
with like a stick shift so I I I drift I
I go to I got ripped I got friends I got
I'm sponsored by a Hoon again these guys
that like Ken Block and all those guys I
don't know but yeah well can pass but
I'm still down with the with the with
the company and they have a place where
there's like 500 000 horsepower cars and
you can just drift in the back all day I
just did a photo shoot for ink magazine
where I shot a uh a truck doing a
burnout with a flamethrower into the
tire so the the tire whips the Flames up
at the back of the truck I [__] burnt
his car too accidentally you've used the
flamethrower I got one I've I have a
flamethrower and I shoot it in my
backyard and set my pool on fire
newly divorced so I'm just [__]
everybody it's pretty cool you got a
pool that's classy yeah yeah yeah it's
on fire
I don't know it's gasoline what do you
mean he's fortunate I guess it's not
something about that that's never
thought of that salt water I don't know
yeah I don't know what kind of pool it
is just a pool you know
I know how to turn the heater on
flame thrower
[Laughter]
so now you're right you're out in
California yeah right you live out there
yeah you got a house yeah you got the
pool yeah you got the nice car yeah you
do the suits yeah all right uh-oh uh are
you going to the grocery store
yeah now that I'm divorced yeah yeah I
don't like I don't like my new
responsibilities but yeah I I cleaned
the house I wash the dishes I clean up
dog [__] in the backyard I uh I changed
the the poopy pads inside the house and
I get my groceries and I cook [__] and I
don't do Postmates because podcast is
not doing great numbers and I'm not as
rich as I used to be after serious five
I mean my business manager said don't
get Postmates anymore
I just do what I'm told okay I just keep
saying where do I [__] go next to
kick ass and how when can I get
Postmates
get me
Whole Foods you go to Whole Foods all
right yeah what do you mean because I
eat clean most of the time so I try to
get that I got a a grass-fed meat
sponsor so I don't have to buy meat nice
but I eat grass-fed meat only unless I'm
high and you know the you know here I'm
like [__] off I eat pizza with turds in
it I don't care yeah but most of the
time when I can I try to eat clean
because I'm older and I'm I still try to
go to the gym as much as I can I still
try to skate and when you're 51 and you
eat McDonald's it's not gonna happen so
I I try hard to do the MMA diet most of
my day okay I try to eat vegetables and
and fruits and [__] you know have you
ever done the uh like the stem cell
injections [__] yeah I've been to
Columbia twice I've had stem cells I
wouldn't be walking without it I blew my
knees out so bad I've torn all my
ligaments to my knees I got a dead purse
ligament in my left knee and when I went
to Columbia the first what happened to
him I I didn't get the thing I got the
thing off the stem cells I got a baby
girl's umbilical cord shot into me
because that's you know in Colombia here
the lore is they can take it out they
take it out of your spine I've had that
too where they take a needle out and
they take the [__] out of your spine and
then they spin it and they get the stem
cells from that and then they inject it
back into your injuries but because if
you're over like 35 your level of stem
cells is low but if you get it from a
baby like umbilical cord that's really
high so I was getting like a hundred
thousand uh I forgot what it's called
but like a hundred thousand stem cells
into my ankles then when I went to
Colombia it's like 20 million and then
they put you on an IV I got it on my
face just because another skateboarder
did it and said it was the most painful
thing he's ever done so I wanted to go
to tell him that it's not that painful
sure logically oh this makes sense I was
wrong but it's a good video
but they put you they inject you with no
anesthesia or anything they just put
these big dirty needles in like past
your kneecap into your knee but it's
like this weird you're like man I really
don't want you to stab me with that but
I know that when you stab me with that
in three months from now my knees gonna
like
hold on again and I can skate and I can
kick again stuff like that like it's
that much of a turn around so it's not
instant it's not like getting a
cortisone it takes like about three
months to start tightening up and then
over a year it gets even better so it
starts to grow regrow things and like my
knee because all my leg what's left is
torn so my shin moves in my kneecaps but
when I got the injections it stopped
move like I used to if I throw a hard
leg kick my shin would move in my knee
and I would tear my ligaments again now
I can dig my shin bone into you again
and my knee stays stiff you need that
yikes it works
it's real good ever been to a wax museum
oh yeah but I I was pretty mad about it
I fought everywhere I think I took a
tour I think I took a mom or somebody
that was here and I was like what the
[__] [__] is this place yeah yeah uh
what do you what are you doing for uh
vacation now I don't have any money how
to go on vacation you don't do any
vacation no okay okay let's go to
patreon.com Alice main check out yeah
and then maybe I'll go on one next year
are you peeinging in the shower [__]
yeah brush your teeth in there not
anymore I used to all the time and then
I saw uh
a comedian the other day make a joke
about the germs that would be on your
toothbrush if it's in the shower that
scares you and it hit me and I was like
right that's it I'm not doing that
anymore but that's like like a week
that's just new I've been washing my
legs too lately you know why people
don't wash their legs yeah I know why I
don't black people do I learned that
from Tom Segura huh yeah so now I wash
my legs I might wash them once a month
right maybe yeah because you figure you
washed the top and it runs down my also
my legs are sitting in jeans all day
they're not like you know what I mean
it's not like I'm [__] so I cut my
legs not a mechanic wearing shorts yeah
I should have already done that what
kind of soap you using in the shower
uh and you're getting all this stuff
right you're the one you're the one
running the house yeah yeah no I I get
soaked from like
if I buy cologne or whatever like I
gotta I go to Keels
okay classy yeah and so if I go there to
get like a face moisturizer I'll get a
bar of soap but I also have hippo
cleanse
because I I [__] a lot and I wash my
toys with it and you know I mean
sometimes if I bone somebody it might be
a little nasty or something like hippo
cleanse my dick
but uh gotta be responsible yeah uh
extra germ like cuts and burns from
skating and [__] so I have hippo cleanse
in my bathroom and in the shower to uh
wash things to make sure they don't get
infected okay so I have a double wash up
that's pretty good I try to stay clean I
don't like being dirty and I've had
staff infections a lot like from
fighting and skating so I really try to
dodge those and use fish moisturizer
yeah every day yep that's pretty good
yeah I tried yeah I'm a bit of a lady I
care about my face too much you know
I'm getting old and like you get you
start to look shittier every day look 51
though no not at all but I think it's
because I'm trying you know keep trying
maybe it's working yeah tight I'm okay
with it
huh what kind of toothpaste are you
using I don't care you don't care I just
get it from the from uh CVS deodorant
what are you using deodorant wise I own
a deodorant company
Hume deodorant it doesn't we don't test
on animals or any of that stuff and it
works yeah that's what I use no that's a
curveball sorry yeah I didn't see that
one coming in promo code Bogan
it's wolf but sure
okay are you flossing every day no I got
oh no I got the the little the ones with
the hand thing on it sure if I eat steak
and [__] I definitely floss if I got
something stuck in there I get it out
what about the fingernails you biting
them are you clipping no I clip them I
clip them short because uh fighting you
don't want to scratch people's necks and
I've you guys are gonna love this
fisting you want to make sure that your
nails are trimmed for that sure yep very
important no questions okay
interesting huh
I mean you're not gonna pull out of this
but I'm just curious at this point
I just want I just want to know what are
you sleeping in
uh big a big one California King
California King yeah nice how many
pillows are you using
uh yeah to sleep when uh I got two I got
one that holds my heads up because I got
you know back problems from all the
injuries and [__] sure so if I get sore
my hips lock up I use one that holds my
head sideways but usually I go to sleep
super high and I have just one pillow
but my wife had four but since we we got
divorced right now I have three any
pillow between your legs are you hugging
one nah no no no sleep on your back
doctor brought that out but I just don't
get I toss and turn too much I just gave
it up a fan on you while you sleep nah
air conditioning
sometimes but usually been naked I
presume yeah you're sleeping nude yeah
okay you wear pajamas I don't wear but
not like a 50s Not Like A the whole
outfit but you do wear something yeah
wear my underwear yeah and uh I'm always
naked especially in the house okay I
don't like clothes you're gonna have a
good good good piece on you I presume
yeah yeah yeah I'm doing pretty good
there you're just so during the day
you're rolling around a house naked
that's how you relax a little bit yeah I
like to Bone a lot so I mean I'm always
boning somebody so do I put a pair of
drawers on now
if I get the mail or something oh yeah
no I'll put pants on for the mail okay
yeah
okay I put box of shorts on at least you
know do you remember your first concert
that you went to uh yeah AC DC and my
mom's stomach and then AC DC when I was
four holy [__] I mean that's both your
mama do an AC DC concert I saw AC DC in
America when I was 17 and I called my
mom and I go mom guess what I just did
and she's like what but I saw AC DC
she's like you've seen him twice I'm
like what are you talking about it's
like I took your once in my stomach and
once when you're four and I was like
well I don't remember that but that
sounds pretty cool
where are you eating dinner when you're
at the house if it's say it's just you
you make yourself something to eat well
you sit down at the table and eat or not
on the couch on the couch you don't have
a dining table you're watching TV I have
a dining table no you have a kitchen
table yeah yeah yeah but oh sometimes I
eat there but mainly on the couch where
my weed box is and the TVs in front of
them I like to watch TV I like to have
TV on what are you watching what's up
fighting or uh Seinfeld movies nah I'm
more I just watch like Meg and jaws and
Rambo and uh and uh I mean that's it
dude
what's the [__] what's the what's the
what's the [__] The Expendables I
don't know no no I don't like The
Expendables too cheesy what's a race not
a racer [__]
yeah the soundtrack is in my head most
of the day and then [__] what is it
Denzel Washington uh equalizer equalizer
I watch equalizer one and two constantly
I mean that's it dude that's it is that
good yeah it's [__] all right I'm
gonna watch mate too that is like the
most I just saw Meg for the first time I
thought it was awesome I swear my
ex-wife I part of the reason she left me
was because every time she goes in the
living room I'm watching Meg and she's
like why would I [__] you you know like
you're a [__] idiot I'm like no way I
mean look at the size of that shark
he seems to get bigger each time I watch
it holy [__] there's two of them
always gets me
sorry
you were down in the count early in the
episode I mean
yeah the uppity [__] is pretty yeah no I
know yeah the Keels ain't gonna help you
bro
[__] California King Ain't Gonna Save
you here now you're trash 100 100
Australian [__] track God damn let me
tell you something I had a feeling that
was gonna happen what a [__] the
[__] ass guy coolest guy I ever met
in my [__] life
I'll tell you that right now
I mean this dude is awesome and I want
somebody doing [__] burnouts at my
funeral I don't know who it's gonna be
yeah I'll do it
I'll [__] do it Jesus Christ ladies
and gentlemen Mr Jason Ellis amazing
thank you buddy buddy what do you got
coming up what do you want the folks out
there to know
the Jason ellis.com is where all my tour
dates are uh yeah I don't get around
that much I'm still pretty new
um but the Jason L show and Hulk versus
wolf it's a free podcast it's available
everywhere a YouTube all that [__]
uh and then patreon.com I do five shows
a week on there so there's a lot of
stuff on there and I have woof knives
clothing and Hume deodorant and I think
that's that's pretty good oh yeah I have
only fans but that's probably not for
this show so yeah check it out why did I
do that if you see someone sign up with
my name it wasn't me I don't read that
on purpose I would stop doing it
buddy truly one of the Most Fascinating
People
I love your show you guys are [__]
buddy good for you for inventing this
great deal thank you you're [__]
awesome yeah Kippy what do you got for
him uh we're all over the road we just
added uh second shows in Denver uh third
show in Chicago might be coming because
the second one sold out Toronto we had
in a second show Phillies every all the
tickets are moving get your tickies uh
we'll see you out there gang gang we
love you to death and we'll see you next
week peace